Nikki Bella and John Cena share a smooch  in the ballroom as Ellen Burstyn steps  in last minute for Maksim Chmerkovskiy  it was guilty pleasures week on Dancing  with the Stars for WWE superstar Nikki  Bella  that meant a sultry Viennese Waltz  centered around Fifty Shades of Grey  [Music]  Nikki's fiance John Cena was in the  audience  he gave her performance a standing  ovation and a rave review meanwhile  Maksim Chmerkovskiy took the night off  citing a personal issue filling in to  dance with his celebrity partner Vanessa  Lachey Alan Burstyn the first-time pro  who was eliminated last week with Debbie  Gibson et reached out to Max's rep who  said there are no further details  regarding his absence at this time  however he appeared to be in good  spirits following the live taping of the  show max's younger brother Val shared  this video to Instagram enjoying a  family dinner with their parents Max's  wife PETA and Val's girlfriend Jenna  [Music]  you